MALE SPEAKER: So it's
my great pleasure
to introduce Bob
Frankston, who imagined
a world with a spreadsheet
before computers really
had a useful thing to do.
And so it was world
changing, and I
think what's really
interesting is when
I met with Bob a couple weeks
ago and we start talking,
we immediately got into
a really strong agreement
and a really good argument
all within about four minutes.
And so I thought,
that's the kind of guy
I want to talk here.
So thanks for coming, Bob.
I really appreciate it.
BOB FRANKSTON: OK.
As some people here
know, my history
goes back well before VisiCalc,
which is actually Dan's idea.
I will go through history,
but let's start the talk.
Hit the space bar.
That's a good way
to move forward.
So I'm going to start
at the end point.
Both of the talk, where
the high-level issues are,
and the sense that I
interested in the endpoints
of connections, and not all
the network crap in the middle.
So the internet itself
is just a technique.
It's the way we can use whatever
is available to communicate.
The problem is that we
have all these people who
think the internet is important.
That's thinking that there is
a thing called the internet.
And they sort of have to
defend it and make it work.
And for me, it's just
that stuff in the middle.
I just start with
what you do with it.
And you mentioned using
VisiCalc, some people at the St
Student Information
Processing Board
at MIT, which I
co-founded in '69, trying
to get people to use
computers back then.
I had a sense they were useful.
Nobody believed me.
And this is that actually
the culture, the Project MAC,
which is in the building that's
inside one of the Novartis
buildings now, which
is the attitude of how
do we make this
technology useful?
What can we do with it?
So I'm skipping outside my
talk, but for me the slides
are mainly a guide.
They try to keep me on track.
There will be lots of points
we can discuss later I'll
just mention.
One of the big insights is
the least important thing
we do is exchange content.
Now that might sound
heretical, but how many people
have ever sent a
copy of Wikipedia?
You just say the word Wikipedia.
You refer to it.
You never send it.
And that's part of the secret
about what makes this work.
Yet all our policies,
all our measures
of broadband and everything,
running out of internet,
are based on the idea we're
shipping exabytes of data
through this one
router, which must
be in the middle of Kansas City.
But for me, the internet is
really about opportunity.
How do we create opportunity
to do things at the-- well,
there's no real edge,
but outside of the net?
And the other important
point is that the internet
is a discontinuity.
When you read the classic
histories of in the internet,
they start with the ARPANET
and have a packet radio.
No, that's nonsense.
Yes, the excellent
technologies were there,
but the interent really
started from a very different
beginning.
It was the revolt against
networking as a service.
You didn't need a third
party along the way
to read your telegram
like a scribe
and repeat it down the line.
You do it yourself.
You just exchang these
meaningless bits.
And one of the really horrendous
legacies we're still stuck with
is the idea the
carrier in the middle
must make a profit for
you to do anything.
And I was reminded of this.
I understand why companies
need to make a profit,
the question is whether
that's the right model.
For example, airlines.
I don't have a better
idea for airlines.
But the consequence
is I'm not going
to be able to get to Los Vegas
tomorrow because airlines
no longer have enough
extra equipment.
So basically, they
canceled my flight
because a gear was
stuck somewhere
and there's absolutely
no resilience.
The whole system shuts down.
And maybe airlines
have to do it.,
but for us to use that
technology for networking
is absurd.
So as I said, the
internet is a technique
for doing things ourselves.
Now, I put in DIO
as a broader point
because doing it ourselves
doesn't mean you do it alone.
It could be doing
it ourselves if you
have communities
that work together.
But it's easy to just
think of DIY as opposed
to depending on a third party.
Do it yourself.
The other thing that we're
going to get to is once meaning
is outside the
network-- oh, I just
realized you're not
seeing my slides.
MALE SPEAKER:
[INAUDIBLE] slides?
BOB FRANKSTON: Yes,
there are slides here.
I'm more coherent than I seem,
because the explanation is up
on the slides.
Speaking of depending
on a third party
and not having eyes in
the back of my head.
Ah, there it is.
I won't go back to
the other pictures,
nor show my beautiful picture
of the trolley in the snow.
That explains why you were
actually looking at me
and seemed to be awake.
I can go all the way back,
but that's not important.
So there's where you
see DIY versus DIO.
You wondered why I was-- OK.
Do I seem more coherent
now that you can see it?
OK.
So what does this mean?
This is really about taking
advantage of opportunities.
And we're limited by
discovering what we can do.
For example, voice over
IP was a discovery.
Yes, we could get to
work in some cases
in the early studies, but how
can you do voice over a-- when
you lose your package,
you got high jitter.
Just like TV.
People thought we
need asynchronous TV.
But some people were
creative and figured out
ways to take advantage
of opportunities.
Now it's not always obvious.
The reason VoIP it
works now has nothing
to do with making VoIP work.
It was the web that
gave us the capacity.
If we try to make VoIP
work, we actually did.
It's called SS7.
Does anybody want to buy
a used phone network?
It's too expensive to maintain.
But the key is to have an
appropriate business model.
And this is one of
the main messages.
So we don't need a third party
the middle like the airlines
do.
Have to run at the edge, to
only do what's profitable.
It's sort of like
depending on the railroad
to get to a destination.
Not many railroads are willing
to tracks up Mount Everest.
So we want to get away from
this idea of the provider making
profit for us to do anything.
The other problem we have with
the current business model
is that providers'
worst enemy, the people
they fear the most,
the existential threat,
are the customers.
There's a customer
buying from Netflix
will remove all the
profit of selling content,
as the cable companies do now.
And there's a slide show
I point to on my site
from the cellular industry
explaining that abundance
is the greatest threat.
That if they don't
prevent abundance,
people are not going
to buy the services.
So if you wondered why there's
a problem with broadband crisis,
it's obvious.
Giving the customers enough
capacity is a losing idea.
So this is not sustainable.
We need to have a
sustainable business model,
and this is, again, Google,
since you use connectivity,
to encourage capacity.
As I said, we exchange
references, not contact.
Capacity is not the
same as bandwidth.
It turns out we have
so much capacity,
we're using, at the
first approximation,
0% of our capacity.
And that's what's a
conflict of interest.
So there is an
alternative model,
which is the way
we fund sidewalks.
The sidewalk owner
does not view the user
as a competitive threat.
But people talk about
privatizing the Mass Pike.
Then Route 30 becomes
a competitive threat.
We already saw this in Detroit.
There's a private
bridge in Detroit.
They try to keep the city
from building a public bridge
because it's competition.
So you've really got to
be careful about what
incentives we create.
Now the resource I describe
as ambient connectivity,
and I use this term for the
idea of wherever you are,
you could just
assume connectivity.
Now this is sort of like
having open Wi-Fi everywhere,
except I don't want to tie it
to any particular technology.
Current Wi-Fi is much
better than it might be,
but it's still a
problematic technology.
But the key is to
be able to assume
we're connected wherever we are.
I'll get more into this.
I add the word permissionless
because people somehow
seem to assume you've got to
show your credentials to prove
you can pay for it.
But how many of you
have to show that you're
authorized to use a sidewalk?
That's the exception,
not the rule.
And the thing to realize is
this whole idea of networking,
we so implicitly have a
provider-centric view.
We talk about the network
as what's important,
and how you maintain
the network.
And as we'll see, our
language, our framework
is infused with a
provider-centric view
of protocols and everything.
What you have to do is
forget about the network.
I want to be able to think
just about the relationships
between the two endpoints and
what I'm trying to accomplish.
It should just work everywhere.
Or you shouldn't have to log
into this or connect to this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One of the
big struggles we've had
is that users want to be
able to define what they get
from an ISP, and the ISP is
usually unwilling to commit.
BOB FRANKSTON: We shouldn't
have the concept of an ISP
because the interent is not a
service that's being pumped out
of the salt mines in Louisiana.
It's what we do with
the available resources.
The internet is a technique.
That's what I'm saying
about flipping the model.
People assume they
have to ask the ISP.
No, you're important.
The ISP should come to you
and say, please, I want a job.
Can I do anything for you?
I'm very interested
in how language works,
so I have to use language
people are familiar with.
So I say open access, even
though words like that
are still provider-centric.
One of the big words we use,
terrible words, is broadband.
What is broadband?
AUDIENCE: Effectively, a
bigger pipe than the other.
BOB FRANKSTON:
Well actually, it's
a technical term that comes
from radio technology.
It turns out the companies that
extended the TV antennas up
the top of the mountain took the
broadband over the air signals
and put it on a coaxial
cable, versus baseband.
And that became-- we're going
to give examples later--
associated with a business
model because that's
the way language works.
And then it became
literally a contronym.
Literally itself has
become a contronym.
A contronym is a word
that's its own antonym.
And the way language
works, literally fills
in the same slot
as figuratively,
so people tend to
confuse the two.
So broadband we use to mean the
internet, when the internet is
really what you tunnel through
despite the broadband business
model.
This is what makes it so
hard to talk about this.
And I have to emphasize, I'm
talking about an architecture,
not any particular
implementation.
So when I talk about having open
Wi-Fi, that's just an example.
It's one way to do it.
What amazes me is how
often it's, oh, we'll
give you wireless mesh.
First, why do I say wireless?
A wire is just a wave
guide for signals.
There's nothing
wrong with wires.
And mesh is just a
particular technology.
And if I've got a fiber that
takes me across the country,
why do I want a bucket brigade?
It's an economic
problem to solve,
and technology's just a means.
What we do have
to do is preserve
the magic of it just works.
And that's the real
architectural goal.
That's the power
of architecture.
Network just disappears.
And apps can use any available
means, including the QR codes.
So if we're just
exchanging a reference,
I just give you a QR code.
So one way to explain
this is our view
of the history of
what I call digital.
Now when I say digital,
I mean discrete symbols.
It doesn't mean 10 fingers.
But the fact that we can
have these sharp distinctions
and you can regenerate
the meaning.
That's the real value.
The zeroes and ones are
going to be regenerated.
But it's also alphabets.
If I write letters,
even-- . pictographics.
Hieroglyphics were
very distinct symbols.
Little off, you can
guess what it is again.
And that allowed the message
to be preserved over distance.
You can carry the message.
If it got a little distorted,
you can correct it.
Smudged.
But also over time.
And we actually had some
forward error correcting
oral traditions,
but that's for when
you want a discussion
of details of language.
But one of the legacies
of the early days
of inarticulate digital
is the telegraph.
We had to use the wire to
keep the single contained,
to maintain the relationships
between the bits,
the endpoints.
So it flooded our skies
with all these wires.
Every call needed its own wire.
And you think that's bad?
Even when we had
wireless, no wires,
we created virtual wires.
This cockamamie idea of
single frequency signaling
creates scarcity.
It's as if we said no
two people in the room
could wear a blue shirt
because it'll be confused.
Interference is not a
property of physics.
Waves pass through each other.
Interference is another
word for confusion.
So whenever anybody
talks about interference,
they're just saying
we're creating confusion.
If you use all the rich
data, and in a sense,
if you look at meaning
come from context,
big data's fundamental.
Information in isolation
is meaningless.
Yet our
telecommunications system
is trying to
carefully preserve--
this is the
inarticulate digital.
We have to carefully
preserve all this stuff
because-- it's a great
hack, by the way.
The tuning fork was a
wonderful discovery back then.
The fact it's been used to
compromise the Constitution
and prevent free speech,
well, collateral damage.
The other reminder is that
business models-- again,
like broadband,
the business model
came from the accidental
properties of history.
The single frequency
single hop signal
gave us the business
model of radio.
And if I make it to CS this
year, I ask about radio,
I've found Pandora is radio.
Tubes and transistors
are no longer radio.
Beware the language.
The talking telegraph
really created havoc.
We had this great technology.
Digital can cover any distance.
And then this guy
across the river
there disobeyed
his father-in-law,
stole an idea from
Elisha Gray, who
retired to West [INAUDIBLE], and
created the talking telegraph
using analog technology,
and made a mess of things.
Distance now became difficult.
Distance used to be easy.
Telegraph would go
over any distance.
Distance became hard.
And with that explicit
understanding,
we could tune things, we could
tune knobs and all this stuff.
But it was very hard to preserve
a signal across the street,
let alone across the country.
So this guy Claude Shannon
did a lot of research,
created this whole
technology for how
to preserve a
signal within wire.
Within the channel.
He didn't use the term wire.
He used a channel.
It wasn't very abstract term.
He called it information for
the same reason physicists,
we'll point out, like
to use words like work.
Well we have giant
brains, all this notation,
anthropomorphic notation.
We use the word communicate
as if these wires carried
our meaning.
And we're still
living in that legacy.
Matter of fact, here
it's more than a century
after that picture I
showed you of the wires
covering all the streets,
yet it's even worse.
All we've done in a
century and a half
is learn how to
take all those wires
and bundle them up very neatly
into little tiny packages.
And worse, we have
multiple bundles and wires
from competing
bundlers, or bunglers,
whatever you want to call them.
And it's even worse.
Inside each of those we
have virtual circuits
to maintain each conversation.
Now how you can maintain a
business model of carrying bits
where there's no longer
any way to compete.
In other words,
they're just bits.
They're generic bits.
How you differentiate.
But the reason we
have the legacy
is we're still stuck
in stage two, the idea
that you need
pipes, pipes, pipes.
And it comes out in many ways.
One is carriers don't
want to become dumb pipes.
Sorry.
That's not the worst
of it, is the fact
we don't need pipes anymore.
Bits are all
self-identified, meaning
it's assembled
outside the network.
We don't need pipes.
Yet our business models
are still pipe-based.
Now the digital technology
that gave us computers
did set the stage
for the future.
But we first have
to-- again, this
is why I brought up
the issue of language.
How many people think physicists
should run the NLRB, National
Labor Relations Board, because
they understand what work is?
Why would a double
E be allowed to run
a school of communications
and the PR department?
Those people understand
communications.
Apparently E's don't because
they confuse information
in the Shannon sense.
How much information is there
in not answering a question?
Or in a pause?
There are people who spend a
lot of time figuring it out,
and you have to slap
them and say, no.
That's a stupid question.
Now this sets the stage for
what I'm calling stage three.
Now we're very interested
in [INAUDIBLE],
but I took a class in spring
of 1973 from Mike Hammer.
Does anybody remember Mike
Hammer, reengineering?
It was studying networks.
So one of things we
studied was ALOHAnet.
How many people here
know about ALOHAnet?
OK.
It was a radio packet
network in Hawaii.
Do It yourself packet network.
There had been various
experiments integrating packet
networks, but I
remember ALOHA was
the one we studied in class.
And basically it was
what any hacker would do.
It looks at a packet
and resends it.
No big deal.
Maybe it's the
latest temperature.
You don't resend it.
You just give them temperature.
I mean, we called it a net.
It was ALOHAnet, but it was a
network in the sense Facebook
is a network, or, sorry,
Google+ is a network.
It's a social network.
That's the problem
with language again.
This is why I'm so
fascinated by language.
The word network is
so general as to be
totally useless
for communicating.
Worse than useless.
It sort of like diplomacy.
You can both use the
same word, but mean
entirely different things.
But you think you're
talking to each other.
And at the end of the class,
some other kid sitting next
to me-- this is May 1973,
did his baseband project.
He took ALOHA and
put it on a coax.
Now I wanted to do it
over the campus network,
it would have been broadband.
But I didn't follow through,
so it doesn't count.
But it was obvious
this is a great hack.
2.994 megabits,
as he reminds me.
That's Bob Metcalfe, you know.
It was wonderful.
But to get his Doctorate he
had to prove to the EE people
that it would perform well.
Turns out he was wrong.
It performed much better
than his thesis said.
So how many of you are familiar
with the paradigms framings?
When you change a paradigm,
everything changes.
So when Copernicus
did his little thing
of moving a reference
point 93 million miles,
it was a nice
mathematical hack, and it
did make navigation easier.
But it had two
side effects, which
he wouldn't have anticipated.
One, it destroyed
people's idea that they
were the middle of the universe.
And that made it
very hard to accept.
And I'm telling you
meaning is not fundamental,
if you want a scary concept.
The other thing it did was
give Newton his physics.
Because suddenly you
could see a uniformity out
of all these disparate
things, and you just
get a deeper understanding.
And in that sense, what the
packet radios forced us to do
was learn how to preserve
meaning outside of the network.
Discover what we can do
with the opportunities.
And that, I argue, is the
real origin of the internet.
Learning how to solve
problems ourselves,
learning the techniques for
using any available resource
as a way to communicate in the
human sense, not just EE sense.
And that's why I say a
fundamental discontinuity,
yet we're still thinking
stage two because, as I said,
language, information,
communications.
It just sounds just like the
railroads of the 19th century.
And in fact, we have a
thing called the Federal
Communications Commission.
What do they mean
by communications?
What's worse is they're
explicitly spun off
from the ICC, Interstate
Commerce Commission, which
managed railroads.
Now that's gone.
It's been replaced by the
Department of Transportation,
which manages the
means we use to travel.
It does not manage the
actual freight itself.
In the meantime,
the FCC is there
telling us what words
we're allowed to use,
how we're allowed
to run elections.
Really weird.
You'd think these people didn't
understand how to communicate.
And we're still compromising
the First Amendment
by creating scarcity in order
to keep the business alive.
So the internet happened when
we're interconnected the LANs.
The LAN, you were , anywhere,
plugged into the coax,
you were just there.
But the consequence
of that was you
could not see beyond
the individual packet.
So therefore, we had
to have a system--
and this is the real insight--
to separate TCP from IP.
And it wasn't just
Vince or Bob Kahn.
There were a number of others.
David Reed locally,
and Dave Clark,
and all these other people.
How do you preserve an
application relationship
independent, when you could just
exchange nothing above packets?
And this where the
end-to-end argument.
You had to have meaning
outside the application.
The earlier slide said
TCP, mentioned explicitly.
What TCP is, it says
transmission control protocol.
Very interesting.
Because if all you want
to do was make sure
all the bits got
through, you keep
retrying til it gets through.
But TCP was also protocol
for cooperatively
sharing the resources in the
middle by detecting congestion,
by backing off.
And what's amazing is
how well that worked.
That it's really a social
protocol for sharing resources.
It's not just a reliable
stream protocol.
And basically, yes,
you can violate it,
but if more than a few
people violate a collapse,
you get immediate feedback,
people used standard libraries.
So it's a whole
interesting discussion
about why that works.
And sociologists should
study this some more.
And I won't go into
problems like buffer blow.
There were lots of other issues.
So where I come into this,
and this much prouder
than doing VisiCalc,
was home networks.
The original triple play plan,
or n-tuple play. [INAUDIBLE]
is a good example.
They would haul a
pipe into your house.
They would put an a ATM
card cage in the basement.
ATM was asynchronous
transfer mode.
The base for DSL.
I'll try to avoid too
much acronym soup.
By the way, ADSL is interesting.
You know why DSL exists?
For interactive TV.
It was not created
for the internet.
That was a later repurposing.
There's a lot of
repurposing discovery.
Hindsight history makes
things look so purposeful.
People have a reason
for everything.
But if you remember
at the beginning
when you had to run a separate
wire for reach relationship,
well those wires,
virtual wires were
inside a pipe or any
other triple plays.
Each phone line was
delivered to the card cage.
In the early days, remember,
the phone companies
owned your phone.
The service was
the conversation.
It was not the wires
coming into your house.
And therefore in
the 1950s, AT&T had
to be sued to allow you
put a box around a phone.
it was a kind of device called
the Hush-A-Phone compromised
the quality of the service and
dispersed their reputation.
Later the Carterfone
allowed your equipment on,
but the Hush-A-Phone, I think
was a more interesting case.
Where the boundary
of the service is.
And you can see the example
of how that works in practice.
Carriers would want to
charge for each IP address
as if it were a phone number.
You're going to pay
for each IP address.
Since they looked
inside your house,
they can do things like
trying to ban webcams
because those were an
abuse of their service.
It really [INAUDIBLE] home.
Repurposing a video distribution
service, rethink connectivity.
And today, the modern version
of that is called Google Fiber.
And Google Fiber's
attitude is you can share.
They're telling you what
you do with the bits.
Now what company
would be so evil
AUDIENCE: Are you referring
to the no servers allowed?
BOB FRANKSTON: No,
that the least of it.
AUDIENCE: That is [INAUDIBLE].
BOB FRANKSTON: No I understand.
Verizon had the same attitude.
And the nice thing
about terms of service--
I'll be nice to the
FCC, so I won't say
fuck them-- but back when I
was doing home networking--
and I'll get into
that-- I basically
ignored the terms of service.
Because the phone
companies said you're not
allowed to add more than
one PC to your home network.
To the router.
They're going to
tell you what you
can do with the device
inside your own home.
AUDIENCE: So for
the Google Fiber
no sharing, you mean
you can't [INAUDIBLE]
community over to watch TV?
BOB FRANKSTON: No,
it's not just watch TV.
If I have a Google
Fiber programs,
I'm not allowed to share that
connection with my neighbor.
Now I can understand
the business model point
of view, which is why you
need a business model that
doesn't create such
terrible behavior.
But are there people
who try to bring,
like housing communities.
You want to bring
broadband to the poor.
You got a gigabit.
That'll serve complete
apartment houses.
Steve [INAUDIBLE] here
uses just a few megabits
to serve the
[INAUDIBLE] project.
So that it's as if you-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE] one gigabit.
BOB FRANKSTON: No it's not.
You play the odds.
Sure.
But let people
discover what it does.
AUDIENCE: Providers
tell you up front, yes,
you may have one
gigabit of bandwidth,
but you only have 5%.
BOB FRANKSTON: Yeah.
Let the people decide
and discover that.
Sure.
But it's sort of
like a sidewalk.
We're going to limit how many
people can live in the house.
This is where you have
the idea of discovering
what you can do from the edge.
I don't want guarantees.
The reason Skype can do video
is because Skype does not
promise to do video.
If they promised video,
they could not do video.
There are a lot of
counterintuitive aspects
here, which is why
you have to start
thinking from the
resource and from outside.
And you also have some
interesting things,
like if you're
above a threshold,
you've got 10 people with 10
connections, you get 100 times
of capacity.
But basically, if you have a lot
of DSL wires, you share them,
you get disproportional
improvement.
It's like a one-lane highway
will get more than three
times the traffic jams
of a three-lane highway.
Because you start to use
the resource effectively.
You fill in the holes,
you accept delays.
And it all depends
on the application.
We're just extending
the word Wikipedia.
Who cares?
A gigabit is wonderful.
Even if you've got a 10 megabit.
Let me share.
Let me decide.
But it affects the
business model.
That's why I keep coming
back to the funding model.
I'm not saying it
should be given away,
we need funding models that
work with societal needs.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: My one
big sticky thing
here still is legal issues,
including intellectual property
enforcement.
BOB FRANKSTON: No.
But that's not in the wire.
The bits are bits.
They have no inherent meaning.
This is a homeopathic
theory of communications,
that bits have a memory
of their original intent.
AUDIENCE: We share
a network connection
that [INAUDIBLE]
multi-family home.
And one person who was
visiting downloaded--
BOB FRANKSTON: Yes.
And this is why lawyers
are one of the greatest
threats to society.
Basically, you
should move the trial
to Salem, which is
the appropriate venue
for such theories.
AUDIENCE: My point is, we
do need, as a society, to--
BOB FRANKSTON: No.
We have to come to the 20th
century, let alone the 21st.
AUDIENCE: But isn't the
fundamental problem referring
to the fact that you're trying
to share the resource that
has a huge level of [INAUDIBLE]?
BOB FRANKSTON: OK.
Let me get through this
and I'll get to this other.
The short answer is we're using
0% of the available capacity.
So before you start telling
me about a shortage,
start telling me where
that shortage is.
When I've got three broadbands
coming through my backyard
and 1% of any one of them is
my full internet connection,
I've already got 100,000
times the capacity.
So what do you mean?
Why do you tell me shortage?
Where's the shortage?
When the police will run a
fiber to their gun detection
sound thing, which only a few
kilobits you need for gunshot,
but deny anybody the
ability to share that.
People now run fibers to
fire alarms and things.
That are terabits of
capacity going unused.
So before you run
about scarcity,
show me there's a problem.
And the other example I won't
get into is meter reading.
Now meter bits are special.
They can't go over
the real internet.
They need their own network
so the phone companies
can go back to triple-play
and collect money
for each meter read.
And if you read the IEEE
numbers about how many gigabits
of capacity and everything
they need to read the meter,
they need a whole
fiber infrastructure,
gigabits capacity.
Though if you run the
numbers, you'll find out
it's less than a bit per second.
But you need fiber.
We're really beholden
to all these myths.
So we need to start
from the edge.
And the other important
point is local connectivity
is more important than
distant connectivity.
We became fixated
on long distance.
Anybody old enough to remember
when long distance would
put fear in your hearts you'd
go bankrupt on a long distance
call?
That's because of the stupid
thing with analog telephony
that Al Bell did.
With digital it's
no longer an issue.
And even more important,
the people we know and stuff
are nearby.
I was reminded of this.
We're so hung up on
social media, the network.
My son last night was
caught-- foolishly
decided to take a
long drive to Phoenix.
And he was going to
go from Indianapolis,
or he was going from
Indianapolis to St. Louis.
It turns out that
outside Terra Haute,
traffic was stopped for 12
hours in the middle of the snow.
Online social media
is no information.
If he had CB radio with him,
and they almost took one,
he could've found out from the
truckers and everybody what
was happening locally.
And so you can get
across the country easily
to get to a website,
but you can't
send a message from your light
switch to the light fixture,
because that's still
using technology
Ben Franklin understood.
We have TV controllers.
There are so many
problems with you
have to be on the
right LAN, you've
got to point the IR
at the right device.
We do all this
work at a distance,
yet we don't realize
it starts locally.
And then interconnect
these local islands
is how the internet happened.
And that's important
lesson I built on.
Actually, we're going to finish.
So what I did with home
networking is I made it opaque.
I was at Microsoft at the time.
Basically I prototyped
it at my house.
I did it for myself.
And I try to do things
that are generalized.
When Dan Bricklin
did a spreadsheet
so he could do his
homework, we just
did a general version of it.
So the NAT is a nice hack.
So people couldn't
peek inside your house.
They couldn't enforce
the terms of service.
You could share all you want.
On occasion they'll try to tell
you, and the problem is yeah,
some people look
at the IP address
and all sorts of how bad ideas.
Accuse you of being a
witch because your bits
don't look right.
But the key is to make it
just so you can give people
the tools to use the
resources available.
How many people worry about
how many gigabits of video
they're showing
within their home?
There's no cost.
It suddenly becomes expensive
once you get outside the home.
So the benefits to the ownership
is you get as many IP devices
as you want.
There's not scarcity of IP
addresses, no meter running.
And right now we ca run
gigabits in the home.
Remember it used to be ten
megabits was very expensive.
Modems used to be
$300 for kilobits.
But we're not quite there.
We still have this perimeter
security, these complex rules.
Instead of abstracting security,
making the application.
We still think it's a
property of the network.
And these all long discussions
in their own right.
And we still don't
understand generic bits.
We have USB, we have SATA we
have FireWire, we have HDMI.
All these special packets,
as if they're are all
so special and different.
I did this display port
here because that's really
an application protocol
which we should be pushing,
but instead we're
stuck with HDMI,
which is equivalent to
the old digital telephone.
Sort of faux digital.
So with home control
we can learn by doing.
But people still
think it's special
because it's within a home.
It's behind a NAT.
When it's really just the
example of a do it yourself
environment.
We have discovered,
for example, want
to solve a problem
connecting devices?
One thing from the edge is, v6
is a dead issue at this point.
Instead we use v4
reflected to the cloud.
Which I think is a terrible
idea, but it works.
It's an example of you
go with what works.
But I won't dwell
on that either.
Another topic.
But we still use wires
to define relationships.
So how do we move
beyond the home?
The answer's very simple.
We do what we did with
the original internet.
We basically interconnect
this islands.
We've already tunneled
between the islands.
When you get a quote,
"broadband connection",
you're really tunneling out
of your home through telecom.
They own the other
end of the tunnel,
but that's a temporary
historical accident.
We won't go into
why it happened.
But we can take the
same ownership perimeter
and expand it out
from your home.
So if you and your
neighbors share,
which some people are already
doing, an apartment house,
you can get many benefits.
To get two major benefits.
One is cost savings.
You share the capacity.
But the other thing is you
can get permissionless ambient
connectivity.
You can now do all
those IP-based devices.
You can buy some now, but the
problem with perimeter security
makes them very
brittle and fragile.
AUDIENCE: It depends on
what the perimeter is.
In our building we
run our own services.
BOB FRANKSTON: Yeah,
But do you have
a WEP or other authentication?
AUDIENCE: It's
been years since I
was using any of those services.
BOB FRANKSTON: No,
but the answers is--
AUDIENCE: A server
you can [INAUDIBLE].
BOB FRANKSTON: Right.
You have that, but
what you want to do
is at least be able to
have devices just connect.
I'm glad to see Google does
not have an agree screen.
But the problem is you get
things like this at Jet Blue.
Now can somebody
explain why first I
have to call my lawyer
before I can call my lawyer?
There's something wrong there.
I've already the
airline terminal.
I've already agreed to much
worse things they could do me,
yet they have me type agree.
This is something
everybody should
do what they can to
get rid of those.
And again, if you
ask people fear,
they'll say child pornography.
They don't have any
better idea, it's
just they've
learned this mantra.
But if we paid
for infrastructure
like we do roads
and sidewalks, we
wouldn't have a need to shut
things down just for revenue.
AUDIENCE: Will you
accept, especially
in neighborhoods like where
my house is, that there
are thieves, drug dealers,
all sorts of criminals using
those public rights of way
to get by with no record
that they passed because--
BOB FRANKSTON: You mean you
let people walk by your house
without signing an agreement?
And without paying you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well the ping is a
totally different issue.
BOB FRANKSTON:
Well ask Rand Paul.
He'd demand--
AUDIENCE: You have a very
different expectation
of how freely usable for
potentially illegal activities
a sidewalk is, compared to--
BOB FRANKSTON: And
this is what's amazing.
We're lucky by accident
in the Constitution days
when people were really
pissed off at the king,
so they wrote the
free speech thing in.
But every opportunity since, the
fear is so-- it's spelled NSA.
And yes, it's amazing
how people fear
what they don't understand yet.
Which means you're not going
to get any discontinuities,
and you're not going
to get any surprises.
Yes.
But an important part
of the whole lecture,
why the First Amendment works.
Why things work despite the
fact that crossing a street
is too dangerous to do.
So if we fund the
infrastructure-- again,
as I keep saying-- as you do
sidewalks, these problems go.
The reason for putting up
a wall, putting fear aside,
financial reasons go away.
Because it's so cheap,
you pay for it once
like a home network.
And then you create opportunity
to discover [INAUDIBLE].
We haven't even started
to explore what we can do.
Because we can do high
value applications.
Like at home control.
I don't know where my
slide is, but home control
is a wonderful example,
because we just
start to discover what we
can do with connectivity.
But one of the lessons I
learned to total control
is that we could do
high value applications.
We call them trophy homes.
There are lighting
scenarios, all these
complicated high value stories.
TVs coming down, the
shades, all this stuff.
We can't do light switches.
OK?
That's the problem here.
Without permissionless
ambient connectivity,
simple things become hard.
It's not just permissionless.
The DNS, the current-- you
must ask ICANN for permission.
There are lots of
other problems,
but if we solve the
financial problems,
we then have an incentive
to solve problems.
We introduce
resilience to the edge.
You connect through
an access point.
You're walking down
the street, you've
got Comcast and all these
others connected to,
and then Google
Maps stops working.
Because one access
point got stuck.
Authentication chain,
somebody broke it.
The protocols of the
edge aren't resilient.
So there's a lot of work
to do better protocols
and have resilience
of the whole network.
Not meshy, necessarily.
That's just technology.
But resilience.
So the old model,
we assume value
is created inside the network.
Thus we could fund the
network out of the revenue.
And that's where the
cable TV companies are.
They own the pipes,
they sell resources,
just like railroads sold rides.
If you go to Netflix
that collapses,
which creates the conflict.
Fortunately there's
a new business model,
which is the one I keep saying.
Just pay for the wires.
They're so cheap.
You put them in once.
It's amazing how inexpensive.
And if we didn't
put the fiber in,
we would have been doing
gigabits over copper.
DSL was running
megabits 25 years ago.
Now it's copper,
right, so not pairs.
You don't follow DSL rules.
You be very innovative, you
do the bundles as a whole.
And at this point, one way
to use copper is to sell it.
Less copper and buy fiber.
I don't care.
I'm just saying the economics
is what drives Moore's law.
And then we won't have the need
to exclude people for no reason
other than forcing
people to pay.
Imagine sidewalks, the
paywall around them.
To show you the value of this,
let's look at a case study.
Philips Lifeline is one of
the local companies there now
in Framingham.
They started locally.
And initially they
just had the radio
from the device going to a
phone and it would dial up.
It worked well enough
for the purpose.
Hopefully the phone
line was not in use,
and all the other things.
But they put it
before, and you can
get it to work enough
times to be useful.
Now people are going to the
next stage, which they carefully
set up connections
to cell phone.
If you set up the Bluetooth
right and use the right
phone, and you've paid your
bill, and the matter of--
and you [MUMBLING].
It can work.
But the problem without
permissionless ambient
connectivity is the
default is failure.
Shouldn't the default
be to just work?
And that's really
what I'm getting to.
The idea that we want
just works connectivity.
Now there are no
guarantees, and this
is why the VoIP
story is important.
Because we can
get voice to work.
It turns out Skype works
much better over lines
that the traditional
phone companies can't
use because their
protocols are all
brittly dependent upon the
network doing everything right,
preserving a path.
Turns out cleverness
can make up for a lot.
So this is why so important
are the incentives
and create opportunities.
And then there's a
whole discussion, which
I won't get into,
is then we can start
rethinking the current internet.
For example, the Post
Office, I understand,
is routing far better than
any of the internet people.
Because it try to
send mail to you.
It sends mail to a place.
That's its job.
You tell your friends
where you are.
So I can go through,
if anybody wants to,
the other big topic we could
do is where are the smarts.
Smarts are valuable.
So people want to
own the smarts.
But if you go into
a restaurant, you
don't want your
wait person knowing
what you're going to eat.
You'd like to have
some say in the matter.
So I won't go into
the challenges,
but obviously there's a
telecom industry which exists
and to rightfully sees
this as a deadly threat.
We have an FCC, which is
trying to transition to IP, as
if they're desperate attempt
to keep us in stage two.
By simply saying IP
is the new phone wire,
but everything else is the same.
You don't transition.
You let the whole thing
fade into the sunset.
At some point nobody's
going to care about it.
You resell the facilities.
And want does one do
with lead acid batteries?
How do you decommission them?
There might be a lot of money.
Somebody find a good use
for lead acid batteries.
You'd make a lot of money.
AUDIENCE: They recycle
them, I thought.
BOB FRANKSTON: As what?
Maybe they do, but
I'm just saying.
The whole internet thing
is just in the infancy.
Everything I read about
it is very special hacks.
There's no general connectivity.
But then again, these
long discussions-- I
just wanted to introduce
these as ideas at this point.
I can also, if you want,
go to the other slide,
which I'm proud of, is how
do we run out of the internet
when it's just a technique?
After hacking at night
here, went to Union Square
for French toast.
And I was told we're
out of a French toast.
We asked, said are you
out of bread, milk too?
He said the guy didn't
know how to make it.
And that's really
those wires are,
is running out of internet.
So any questions?
Anybody confused?
Anybody awake?
AUDIENCE: So what happens
to your do it yourself
home small community
network when it breaks?
BOB FRANKSTON: What happens
if your water pipe breaks?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
get it serviced.
BOB FRANKSTON: Yeah.
So we'll have the new plumbers.
And in fact, I'm
actually trying to find
people who want to start.
In other words, the
point I'm making
is I'm actually in favor
of business, capitalists,
and all this.
It's just you've got to
have rational businesses,
and the model changes.
If you want to read a book
"Railroaded", by Richard White.
It's a wonderful
story because it
tells how the railroads in
the West-- this is opposed
to the ones in the East, which
have different densities--
were never financially viable.
That's why you've got the FCC.
Or subways in New York
were never viable.
Each infrastructure, you have to
look at how these centers work,
what's the business model?
Instead of just
continuing forward.
So yes, if we're viewing
a time and materials
model as a business,
we need plumbers.
Of course they're a time
and material business.
Your plumber does not charge
you for the cost of water
at the price of whisky.
When you buy flour you
don't pay for the cake.
So you have to understand
where the values is added.
Question back there?
The first step, one thing to
do, and people are already
doing it, the first step is
education and understanding.
But if you're in
an apartment house,
get your friends and
neighbors to basically make
that a connected zone.
Because petitioning
the city is hard,
because there's too much
education, the language,
everything makes it very hard.
How can you even
talk about the FCC
when they were created to
keep a business model alive?
They're not a technology
They were designed
as part of a deal
with AT&T to make
AT&T viable as the stewards
of our ability to communicate.
Things have sort of
gotten out of whack.
And they also got
a right to do it
based on spectrum allocation.
But you understand
how hard it is
to get people to
think differently,
but if you change economics,
if your building--
and there are a
million buildings-- so
if you start to
get your building
to be a connected zone,
and work out from there,
repeating the history
of the internet,
you start to get to an
alternative which is viable.
And I think that's the starting.
AUDIENCE: When you start to
get, having been involved
in small building
connectivity zone
efforts over a couple of
decades, problems you have
is still, as far as I
know, too much expertise.
BOB FRANKSTON: Yeah.
If you want a
problem, it's really
a problem in California,
the Bay Area.
Too many people who
understand too much.
That's my parallel to put
in fiber, ripped out fiber.
So yes.
It's a matter of venue
shopping and set example.
AUDIENCE: But more than this,
plumbing isn't a simple thing.
But plumbing was simplified so
that it could become a trade.
And by having it
established as a trade,
regular people can become
people that maintain plumbing.
You need that for networking.
BOB FRANKSTON: Well
actually, remember,
I did that already
for home networks.
When I first started
doing home networking
in '95, think of
the reaction I got
when I said people are going
to maintain their own home
networks.
So I did a couple things.
First thing, remember I had this
position having been in a class
where we were doing this stuff.
So I knew there was
nothing hard there.
Nothing secret.
I just had to remove
all the things that
made it hard like configuring IP
addresses and things like that.
I've learned a lot since.
There's a lot of ways they
can make it even simpler.
So yes.
Part of it is this is why I talk
about the connectivity of net
routing I compare with crossing
a river by jumping on icebergs.
Turns out we have bridges.
Just use the bridges.
It's like the Post Office
delivers to addresses.
So insights like that
make things much simpler.
All hubs and routers
should be self-diagnosing.
But until we have a market
incentive to do this,
it's going to be hard
to make that happen.
Unfortunately, I
was at Microsoft.
I was able to keep
them, and I purposely
made sure they had no
way to monetize it.
To control it.
But they did get value
out of the connectivity.
Just like Google has a
value out of connectivity.
The more people can connect--
even if 99% of the traffic
is local, you can still start
to offer all these new services
and these new innovations.
But I am actively
looking for people
to work with who do want to
do business in both educating
people on how to
do it themselves
and providing the
appropriate expertise.
So yes.
I don't expect most people to
want to do their own networking
or build their own networks,
but there's no reason
that it has to be hard.
We're just used to it.
The same as DNS.
We have this whole
legacy because so much
of today's internet goes
back to the mainframe
days, port numbers, all these
issues, which are legacies.
We've learned a lot since we
first did the current internet.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, to
[INAUDIBLE] idea
up, you just have
to make it easier.
But you mentioned a problem
being firewalls and such.
BOB FRANKSTON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: One of the [INAUDIBLE]
benefits of that is I
think at one time if you
put a Windows computer
on the public [INAUDIBLE], it
would compromise in 10 minutes.
Definitely less [INAUDIBLE].
BOB FRANKSTON: Yes.
And when I first did it,
what I was saying is OK,
v4 closed the ports by default.
But IPv6 or IPsec, we
wouldn't be stupid.
We designed it to be aware.
Now it turns out
we're still stupid,
but that's another issue.
But we can't depend
upon permanent security.
So now anybody know the
Maginot Line in France?
And how how well
it worked for them.
Now it turns out Andre Maginot
actually was not stupid.
He knew you still
needed an army.
But he made a mistake.
He died.
And the politicians
then said, army?
We don't need no army.
We've got a wall.
So people are building
in these hyper things.
But look at Google's problem.
Chromecast is on
the wrong network.
The device doesn't work.
So the answer is yes.
We have to first have a
better security model.
Because when you go to
Starbucks that same machine
gets connected.
That's based at the
application level,
the software level doesn't
depend on the firewall.
In my model, even if you
have permissionless security,
you still can have
legacy stuff protected.
So I'm not saying we
get rid of all that.
I'm looking new opportunities.
AUDIENCE: One of
the big incentives
to have an apartment
network, basically.
A small community
network when I was
having a college-ish
lifestyle, was
that we could have our server
serving the copies of our CDs
to us [INAUDIBLE].
Now that isn't done anymore.
Maybe it's done centrally.
Do you see obvious
ways that Google
could enable that
sort of community hub
when we're otherwise serving.
BOB FRANKSTON: It's interesting.
One of the things that
Western Digital is selling
is a personal cloud,
which is basically
a disk in your house
as a server, Pogoplug.
A lot of people doing it, so
I can easily see products.
Because if you want to
watch multi-screen 3D
ultra high definition video,
it would be nice to cache
on a server right
in the building.
It's interesting.
This is sort of a
Maraschino cherry problem.
Maraschino is you take a cherry,
take all the cherry-ness out
of it, then add it back.
And in a sense, we've done
such a good job of conquering
distance, we have to
put locality back in.
But that's pragmatic.
I mean, there are two
reasons to [INAUDIBLE].
One is performance.
And fine, put a
cache server there.
You can put that in a box.
Chrome PCs should be able to
work with local cache as well
as remote.
By the way, a little footnote.
Be careful about the word cache.
Sometimes you'll
explicitly put it there.
You want to make sure this
information is there in case
you get disconnected versus
just for performance.
You've got multiple issues.
So you can easily
have protocols that
allow peer sharing locally.
This is content-centeric
networking.
So lots of reasons for doing it.
But you also want your
thermostat, your other devices,
to work within your house when
your connection further out
goes down.
So we have to understand
that the relationships are
separate geographically.
So there are reasons for
having geographic proximity.
Sometimes I want a
light switch to say turn
on the light in this room.
And you might use techniques
like IR not for the message,
not for sending a
message, just so you
know what room you're in.
Again, that's why
I'm saying we have
to rethink a lot of what the
internet is as opportunity.
And the distance
stuff, yeah it's nice,
but we forgot there's
a physical world there.
CB radios, we need to
do virtual CB radios.
So next my son is stuck on
I-70 outside of Terra Haute,
the truckers and stuff have a
local social network, not just
CB radios.
Though it's probably
nice that nobody else
has CB radios
anymore, knowing them.
AUDIENCE: You made a comment at
the beginning about something
like most [INAUDIBLE]
involved in sharing.
BOB FRANKSTON: Well, we
don't exchange content.
We exchange references.
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I was trying to--
BOB FRANKSTON: When I say
Wikipedia instead of giving you
a copy of Wikipedia?
AUDIENCE: Right.
BOB FRANKSTON: Yes.
You want me to expand on that?
That's a very interesting topic.
Because I used to give
my talks and ask people
how much do we compress the
Encyclopedia Britannica?
And I say to an ISBN number.
And if you're a
communication theorist,
you want to fit it
into the old model,
you say, well the
ISBN is a dictionary
just like any of the coding
we use is a dictionary.
But remember, in
communication theory,
you have out-of-band signalling.
You have an out-of-band clock,
which enables a three kilohertz
line to carry more than
three kilohertz because
of precise timing.
But then I decided
that's nonsense.
it's too hard.
It's really that we're just
making references to things.
And really that's
what language is.
You send URLs.
Now URLs have URL problems.
And then, so your effective
capacity is meaningless.
This is why clocking the number
of bits of value is bad enough.
It's already inversed.
The longer the movie, the
less valuable each bit is.
But you can't even measure.
Same movie can be
a terabit or it
can be ten bits depending
on whether you just
need a reference
or you need a copy.
My mother wanted to send a
toy to her grandson in Seattle
from New York.
I said, fine.
I'll have it there in an hour.
I returned it to Radio Shack,
gave my brother the number,
and he bought it for him.
AUDIENCE: The bit
usage, bit used driver
has been people watching
movies and such.
BOB FRANKSTON: It actually
turns our that's not that big.
That's what Akamai is about.
They're cached locally.
There are two ways
it's not a big thing.
Number one, it's cached locally.
Number two, Netflix
does the compression
that the originally
DSL people only envy.
So at two megabits, they can
give you a high definition
experience.
You don't really care
[INAUDIBLE] picture.
You want to enjoy the movie.
A cute idea would be
to put a camera on,
and if you're enough
feet away from the TV,
they'll de-res it
because you're not
going to see the extras reses.
When you come closer-- the point
is there are no rules here.
AUDIENCE: But my
point about that
is that is a lot of what
people consume from an ISP.
BOB FRANKSTON: Well, consume
is an interesting word,
but we'll put that aside.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A lot of how they're
sending bits or receiving bits.
What we've found with
the service I work on
is that if you call something
caching rather than keeping
a copy, then the content
owners are much more
willing to allow you to have
a copy on the client side.
Therefore, community
networks that
merely cache the video in
ways that the [INAUDIBLE].
BOB FRANKSTON: Yes.
Our language, our legal system.
Well, our legal system is
still in the 13th century.
Instead of science,
which tests ideas,
our legal system proves
things by example.
Not that I have anything
against lawyers,
but I have something
against lawyers.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.